まず銃の意味だ。雨がついとるやろ。で、
下のこれ思考という字やね。これどういう
意味なんや?これが分からんと授況分から
んやろ。これの教えなんだから。で、これ
は雨をするという意味なんだ。で、下これ
はね、人間の姿なんよ。頭に曲げを言って
ないから後ろが平らになっとるやろ。で、
首で手で足やろ。こいつは雨をするという
のは火球の巫女とか不っていうかね。氷主
みたいなか巫女なんだ。で実際に偉い人
偉い人はそういう現場で雨声なんかしない
。さっきの神様に聞くああいうこともやら
んのだ。あれはみんな不巫か法か主。これ
がやることは現場の人間ないじゃん。
ということは雨をする現場の人間神の声を
聞いたと思って実際自分の本能を聞くこと
ができるそういう人間の教えなんだ。だ
から非常にこう現実的なだから資の譲渡の
あれは資やな資は同になるんだ。非常に
こう指弁的同居を見るとまるで哲学やろ。
で、授教の方は現実的なんだ。実際に自分たちであれしとるからね。だから我々は授教の方を信用したらええ。同胸の方は別的やもんでなんかこうな、必ずあれみたいに理性で考えとるわね。
1個質問いいですか?ヤ和魂とか仏教とか
動物行動学はこれいいっていう人結構聞く
んですけど授教は僕の周りだとあんまり
こう役に立つってこ言ってる方があんまり
校長以外知らなくてこれなぜだと思います
か?
[音楽]
あれは昔の受教学者がちょっとサボとった
んやな。今ねも特に申しなんてのは呼んで
みるとね解釈が間違っとるわ。解釈でき
なかったんや。だから役にも立たんのや。
だけど我々のような現場の人間は
ものすごい役に立つんや。それに書いて
ある通りにやったらその通りの答えが出て
くる科学やね。だから今までの授教学者と
かああいう連中はちょっと偏裁やったんや
ね。自分で考える力がなかったもん。で、
中国のそれも2つに分かれ趣旨と妖名、
要名学と趣旨学ろさらに2つに分かれて俺
が正しい、俺が正しいと言ってるような
状態やからこれが絶対というものはないね
。あれからね高知症を出て高知症で仏教を
やったもんで今度は授教もやっとかんと
いかんなと思って授教の勉強会してもらっ
たんやその時にどうしても納得できんわけ
よ。先生の言うことが。で、勉強会の
始まる1時間前にその先生と会って色々
わーっと質問していくんよ。これこうや
ないかこうやないか。そしたらなんとね3
回目俺は生まれて授況を始めて3回目だ。
俺が先生やったぜ。こんな程度かと思った
よ。今度は別のとこでね、授況の勉強会が
あるというもので行ってみたら猛子をやっ
とった。こので今俺がもう1番使う猛子の
不同心を動かさざるというところをやっ
とってそれを聞いたんやけどね。これ全く
別の人なんやけどどうしても納得できん
ないでここずっとこうおかしいおかしい
おかしいおかしいて言うとったら首になっ
ちゃったよ。追い出されちまって。その
程度なんやで。
仏教の場合だと元々陰動の言葉だったのをこう役の家庭でっていうのは分かるんですけど授教って漢字じゃないですか?それを書き下し部分にしてっていう子どこで校調がサボっちゃったって言ってる部分があるんですか?
つはねが完全に解釈してないっていうのがあるわね。今こんなもの作ってもらったもんで解釈は深くなるわね。当時の日本だったらまだやよい時代やろ。その頃できたものやろ。
授況もあるもということは字の意味は当時
の意味じゃないといかんじゃない。だけど
役を見てみると今の役でやろうとするんや
ね。だから無理なんやけどね。授況みんな
あれするけど例えば人ギ条
っていうやろ。あれおかしいと思わんやっ
たかな?人とは何かトレーニングして人に
なる。義になる。霊になる。さっきの霊や
な。地これも手に入れることができる。金
はどうや?人想が自分を信用するんやで。
自分がどんなに頑張ったって思想を信用さ
せれんやろ。だからあいつは5条と読まず
に人義
の4つを身につけたら人は信用すると読ん
だらええやないか。そういうとこを誰かが
5条と訳して人地震を1列に並べたら
みんなそうだそうだ考えもせずにそれが
正しいで何万千年かやってきとるんやで。
ここがな、文化系の血管じゃない。考え
にゃ。それ考えてだからね、人ギを言う人
に人とは何か、義とは何か、霊とは何か、
地とは何か聞いてみたら答えが出てこん
ない。人とは何か知らずに人という言葉を
使っるんだ。
校長と授教の出会いはどういう面でだったんですか?
あれになったから仏教が大体理解できた知の夜時になおったもんでな、結構面白いということが分かってこれは役に立つぜとだったら仏教と並んどる授況だったら同じやろうと思ってそいつもやってみようと思ってあっちこっち探し回って教えてくれるとこ探してそこで教えてもらったんやけどね教えてもらってみたらもう
1つ関心んのやみんな怒るけどね出すなら
言ってね。だけど授況はそこで止まっとるね。
え、結局授況の解釈勉強はどういう風にやったんですか?
自分でやったんじゃん。ずっとともかく読んで正しい解釈を作っていってこれのおかげでなと。
こんなありがたい事象はないぞ。こういうものを作れる人が日本にいたということは幸せやと思わないかんよ。特にね、中国人の解釈は間違っとるとしょっちゅ書いてあるよ。それだけのことができる人や。
講師は週の後で週が正しいんだということ
を言って週の具体的な歴史をずらっと調べ
ていったんだ。こうやったらうまくいった
、こうやったらうまくいったというのを
まとめて論を作ったんやね。だから科学だ
というのは実際に起こったこと。実際に
起こったことで実際に解決してる。だから
正しいんや。聖書が正しいというのとは
ちょっとあれが違うんや。
場合だとどうですか?
申しね、我々が呼んでみると申しは天才ね、場所によってはね、講師が説明できないようなことまでちゃんと説明しとるな。申しを完全に読めればもうそれが最強やろうね。中国の方は授教について調的にはこう学んでるっていう印象なんです。
ええ、授教っていうのはその権力者にとっては非常に都合の悪いなんか起こるとお前のせいだて言われるわけよ。
お前がダメだからこんなことが起こるん。
実際に国が潰れるのはそん時の皇帝がダメ
になって国が潰れるからね。だから授教は
もうできたら否定したいから飲酒春講公衆
は春やな。戦国それから真る真の思考艇の
真の思考艇は授教を抹殺しようとしたや
文章工況の本を全部燃やしちまう。授況
学習はみんな行き上にしちまって授業から
逃れようとしとるわね。
それぐらい指導者には都合の悪い学問が頑張らんとダメやぞというそういうやつなんよね。これで最後に仏教と授教の関係についてだけ整理したいなと思ってまして、
[音楽]
最終的に到達したい地点っていうのが、ま、それぞれあると思うんですけど理想の状態っていうのがで仏教と授教それぞれ何なんですかけ?
あのね、仏教はもう分かってるじゃない?如来よ。
如来とは何かをよ、1回調べてみてごらん
。そうそ分かる。
[音楽]
授況の場合は女になればええの。そうする
と字が一緒じゃん。女というのは尿の心
じゃん。だから到達線一緒ということない
。これが訳せてないよ。みんな見てごらん
。語の中にその弟子が尋ねる一言も持って
将来守るべき言葉ありやと。そしてそれに
ついてね、それ女かって女だよ。くれやね
。その聞いたやつはね、なんか意味が
わからんのや弟子がね、そうやったかね。
誰かにあれ何なんやと言って聞いてみる
わけよ。そうすると風の道、風って講師の
ことやな。の道は中女のみて女に中なる
ことのみて言って答えてあ、なるほど言っ
てわかったというそういう一分があるで
その役がね
というのはとジョのまこれ特と言ったら
ええかななんだって言ってあの説明して
あるわけと女なら2文字じゃんだけど質問
は1文字でって言っとるだからと女の2
文字やないん
女に中なることを守り続けよと。これが
論語の道なんや。授教の道なんや。だから
情を正しく理解す。で、その頻度は仏教の
如来にあるから如来とは何かをよく考える
、勉強する。そうしたら自然に授況も
分かってくる。
仏教と授教はこうどっちがどんな人にお勧めとかありますか?
あれね、歴史を読むとね、お茶様はどうすれば苦がなくなるか。この区というのは白のだ。普通の区じゃないんだよ。普通の区とシ白の
[音楽]
つに分けるんだ。で、シハックというのはなくならんのだ。人間な。
で、それでおかしいと思って、そいつも
なくそうとするわけで、当時の
ウパニシャド哲学ではお前肉体があるから
そういう宿泊が出るんだから精神は違うん
や。精神は心身逃げ論やからね、昔から。
で、肉体を死ぬとこまで持っていくんや。
そうしたら精神の方が有越するからその区
がなくなるぞと言われる。これが当時の
ウパシャド哲学におけるあれの作り方やっ
た。区のなくし方やってね。こいつを7年
やったかな?やってみるんや。ところが
ちっともその区がなくならんのや。で、
ここが逆村の偉いとこや。あ、それやり方
が間違っとるんやと。理論が間違っとんだ
からもうこれやめということで森の中で
修行しとったのはやめて森から出てきて
ミレーガーという川で体洗ってそこで座然
を組んでたらスジータという女の子が現れ
て栄養をつけてくれるわけや。重を伸ばし
てくれるわけで、体力を回復した後でそこ
に生えとった母材樹の木の下で座然を組ん
で瞑想するんや。で、瞑想してから8日間
でもう完成したんだ。如来になったんだ。
これはもう仏教のやり方がいかに優れとる
かという意味やね。たった8日間やで。
苦業して7年間やったってダメやって。
それが自分のやり方でやってみたら8日間
でOKになって授況の方は行使が自由に
なる。これ同じことなんや。如来になると
いうのと自由になるというのは同じこと
ない。講師は自由になろうとして15歳
から学問を始めてでずっと進歩していって
80過ぎてからあこれで自由だというとこ
まで行ったんや。女を完全に手に入れたん
やね。ということは70年かかるんよ、
授況のやり方は。だから我々は今進歩する
のに授教のやり方で進歩しとる。学習やね
。だからせっかくだったら仏教のやり方
混ぜたら仏教のやり方は少年症状だと思っ
とるけど違うぞ。少年やぞ。そいつをやる
と非常に早く進歩できる。ミックスすりゃ
ええじゃん。
何も我々は坊主でもなけりゃ授況の学者でもない。授況の生徒でもない。いいものはみんな使えばいいん。そういうことからな。トレーニング抜きに国ここへは行けない。全てトレーニングだ。
[音楽]
授況についてはまた他の動画でも詳しくお話いただきたいと思うので
うん。授況はもうあのすごく長くなっちゃうからほんのちょんちょんとつまんであれするだけや。
そいつを統合するのは自分たちの仕事やで
。それとね、最後にちょっと1つ言っとく
とね、ショート動画がち流れるやろ。あれ
に関しては私はチェックしてないから。で
、それに関する苦情は受け付けません。
諸君があれを切って張り合しただけやから
ね。それを1つコメントはね、こっちまで
届かんから。だからもしうちに対する
コメント文句があるやろなあ。バカだバカ
だと言うんだから。だからそのコメントは
とかヨっスクールを支援する回という
メールくれれば時間があれば答えるし直接
の方がよく分かるからね。相手がどこが
分からんかが分かる。だからヨット
スクールを支援する会の方にメールを送れ
ね。精神に関する色々論争があるし、
いろんなことを言う人がおってみんな自分
が正しいと言うんだから。セミナーに奇数
月に東京名古屋大阪とやってるからもし
それに参加したい人数に制限があるもんで
ヨッスクールを支援する会と塚ヨット
スクールを支援する会のホームページを見
てもらえばでそこに申し込んでもらえば席
は取ります。ただし満席になったらもう
ちょっと勘弁願いたい。
これはね、消防法によってそこの部屋の人数以上に入れてはいかんのだということをよろしく。
リンクも動画の概要欄にも記載します。
[音楽]